[Music]
relax
[Music]
breathe
hey
[Music]
relax
[Music]
breathe
ugh
maintain
relaxation
using the breath
and let go
of all describing
experience
let go of even the intention
to empty let go
of even that
and just keep using the breath to
relax
position yourself comfortably
do not be rushed
trying to just extract something from
this emptying meditation
just ease into
the surrendered relaxation
i will just breathe and
relax and see
what transpires
as you get comfortable
and use the breath more and more to
maintain a state
of relaxation
where you are not describing your
experience
you will notice the power of
language dissolves
become aware of the limitations
of language
as you keep breathing
and relaxing
notice how your mind is quieting
the behavioral pattern
of the active mind
is quieting
and naturally
the feeling of relaxing
into emptiness takes place
keep breathing
and relaxing
no need to use language
no need to describe
experience
just breathe
and relax
and i want you to visualize
that you're very breathing
and relaxing
is like the empty
sky
the very empty sky
it's always present
habitually overlooked
as this emptying meditation
quiets the mind
it also stops the habitual
overlooking of the empty
sky
that is always present
and as you breathe
and relax
into the visualization of the empty
sky
notice how the clouds
will appear and
disappear in the empty
sky
so envision
the thought the emotion
the sensation perception
belief object
experience as the cloud
that arises and passes
in the very empty space
of the sky
take another deep breath
and relax
into the very empty sky
in which these clouds appear
and disappear
the very active busy mind
is perpetually
appearing as clouds
always needing to stay busy
always needing something to do
and when we just take a deep breath
and relax
into the always present empty
sky in which all of the
activity of mind takes place
we become aware of
awareness
we become aware of
being
we become aware of i
am
exist
the most perpetually
habitually overlooked
first principle
take another deep breath
and relax
into the very empty sky
of i am
i exist
being aware
in which all of the activity of mind
appears and disappears as clouds
and as we use the breath
to deepen our relaxation
we practice quieting the mind
that is constantly drawing us out to the
clouds
and we relax more and more
into the very empty sky
we'll also notice that as we quiet our
mind
the very process naturally
dissolves our
conditioning
no longer attached
to all of these onion layers of identity
notice how as you take another breath
and relax
into the empty space of i
am
you notice that the very empty space
of i am is the same
empty space for everyone
everyone has the same
empty sky
in which the clouds of mind
appear and disappear
and as you recognize
that sameness i
am i exist
aware being empty sky
recognize that the
onion layers of conditioned identity
dissolve
when you are the i am
empty sky
where is
your career
where is your religion
where is your country and the flag
where is your political affiliation
where is your family where is your
friends
where is your co-workers
where is your social accounts
and most importantly
of all where
is your name
take another deep breath
and relax
and as you take this next big
inhale
really
tap in
to the dissolving of the layers
of identity
tap into the realization
of the dissolving of the layers of
identity
the very netty netty not this
not that i am not
my career
i am not my religion
i am not my country or its flag
i am not my political affiliation
i'm not my family i'm not my friends
i'm not my co-workers i'm not my social
accounts
i'm not the thoughts i'm not the
emotions i'm not
the experiences i'm not the beliefs
i'm not the perceptions and i'm not the
sensations
i am not even
my name
relax
i am not even my name
all of those are onion layers of
conditioned
identity all of those
are clouds that appear and disappear in
the
very empty sky of
i am
the very shared impersonal
eternal empty sky
among us all
the same awareness the same
empty beingness
take another deep inhalation
and exhale and relax
and as we take this next inhale
on the relaxation of the exhale shake
away
empty away all of the conditioning
take another inhale
and on this relaxing exhale shoot
all of the empty conditioning down
through your feet ah
shed it like snakeskin
and abide in the very formless
subject presence energy
of being aware i
am empty sky
notice how all
of the activity of mind
is a distraction from self-inquiry
it's a distraction from the fundamental
question
of who am i
take a breath
and relax into the question who
am i
relax into the understanding that the
activity of
mind the appearance and disappearance of
clouds
is all conditioning
to keep us away from self-inquiry
into the question who am i
because then the very activity of mind
the very onion layers of conditioning
dissolve and the ego
fights for its sweet sweet life
by keeping us occupied
in mind
take a deep inhalation
and as you relax into the question who
am i
imagine yourself
turning inward
and relaxing into the empty sky of
awareness
and envision as you turn inward
that the mind quiets
and that the onion layers of conditioned
identity
dissolve and you relax into the
empty sky of awareness of i
am
keep relaxing using the breath
and envisioning yourself
dissolving all of the
layers of identity conditioning
by turning inward
and abiding through the breath
through relaxation through the
non-describing
of experience as the empty
sky of i am
ah
take another deep inhalation
and again on this exhale relax
in that turn inward with the question
who am i shedding all of those onion
layers
of identity conditioning and just
relaxing
in the timeless being presence
of i am
another inhalation
and relax into the empty
i am no conditioning
no describing no identity
leverage this visualization
of the mind turning
inward onto the empty
space of awareness of i
am
and leverage the visualization of the
activity of mind as clouds appearing
and disappearing and using the breath as
a tool for relaxation
for the mind to turn inward on
the empty awareness of i am
ah and you'll notice that the more
that you use the tool
of breath to relax
to stop describing experience
and to just abide in the empty space
of i am
to do absolutely nothing
and to just sit
on your living room couch
when you wake up in the morning or go to
sleep at night
on the bed just abiding in the empty
space
of i am
you'll notice the mind naturally quiets
the clouds become less
and less intoxicative
you become less and less lured out
to the clouds and rather you relax
more and more into the empty sky in
which the clouds appear and disappear
and the natural relaxation sets in this
is what is called
being this is what is called awareness
this is the very i am
of the god state
that we share it is
impersonal and it is eternal
and this is what is meant by god
realization
this is what is meant by capital s
self realization
the very fact that you are
not what you are
the what you are is the layers
of identity and conditioning
that you are is the
empty space of i
am
the shared impersonal eternal
god state
take another deep inhalation
exhale and relax into this god state of
empty awareness
pat yourself on the back
good job way to go
love yourself accept yourself
exactly as you are for you
are god you are the absolute
you are ineffably perfect
and free already and always
so congratulations on the progress so
far
become proud of yourself become in love
with yourself
respect yourself
accept yourself exactly
as you are
and recognize that it is god accepting
respecting and loving exactly
as god is
now you can tell as you've moved away
from the downstream
fluctuations of mind
and you've moved more upstream
beyond all of the layers of identity
conditioning to the pure
empty bare sky
of awareness being i am the god state
you've noticed this shift upstream
you've noticed this shift into what is
permanent into what is eternal
into what is infinite consciousness
infinite awareness infinite
beingness infinite i
am i exist
take another inhalation
and relax into the beauty
of what you've rediscovered
into what you've recognized as
your most upstream
natural state i
am
for most of creation
this is enough
let's get most of creation to this
point of emptying
of all the onion layers of identity
conditioning
down to the pure bare empty
i am god state
for those that want to explore
the next level of
emptying
the advanced practitioner level
go ahead and take another deep
inhalation
and relax
if you haven't
shifted your identity
from the
fluctuations of the clouds of mind
to the formless empty
sky of awareness of i
am
practice that first
40 or so minute
emptying meditation
repeatedly as you are called to it
until you make the shift in identity
permanent from being the mind
of the person
to being the sky
of god
the shared impersonal eternal
empty sky of god in which
all of the clouds of phenomena
appear and disappear
make the shift permanent
it's all about identity
empty yourself of the conditioned
identity empty yourself
of the fluctuations of mind
turn inward with the self-inquiry the
question
who am i using the breath
to relax
and becoming aware of oneself
as god as
the empty sky in which
all phenomena appear and disappear
so again repeat that first 40 minute
or so segment
as you are called to
to empty yourself
of your conditioning
of your identity
and to make the shift
upstream
to the empty pure
bare sky
of i am
the god realization the capital s
self realization
all right
now for the advanced practitioners
the next stage of emptying
in the first stage you can say that we
emptied our
conditioning to the god realization
capital s self-realization
state
and in this second part of the emptying
meditation
we will be emptying ourselves
of all that is we will be emptying
ourselves
of creation itself we will be emptying
ourselves
of god of the capital s self
so take a deep inhalation
and relax
now notice how
you are the very
source
of awareness
and of reality
notice how you are the very source
of all that is at play with itself
you are the source of love
light leela the divine play
the universe at play with itself
you are the source of that
you are the source of the great i am
the one god self
exploring the creation
so take a deep inhalation
and recognize that you are the universe
observing and experiencing itself
and exhale
[Music]
relax relax
into the awareness that the entire
universe
is you i
am the entire universe
i am all of god's love light unity
leela at play with itself
in divine exploration
so really shift your identity
to all that is
take another deep inhalation
and really visualize your identity as
all that is and exhale and relax
i am all that is
i am all that is
i am all of the oneness
i am all of god
i am all of the aware
being i am experiencing
exploring the divine creation
i am all of it
so once you've turned the
entire creation
once you've turned all that is
once you've turned even the great i am
the all-inclusive awareness
itself into this
very
bouncy substance
you've turned it into a very bouncy
object and now i want you to empty
yourself
of all that is
empty yourself of the very bouncy
object of all
of creation of even
the all-inclusive awareness
itself empty yourself of the
god-realized state
empty yourself of the capital s
self-realization
state
no more creation
no more all that is
no more all-inclusive awareness
just
ineffability
notice
this ineffable
and shift your identity
to this ineffable
shift your identity
from all that is
from all creation
from the all-inclusive awareness
to the very ineffable prior to it
the very source
of awareness and realities
shift your identity
to the ineffable
source
of infinite creation
practice emptying yourself
of not only the
fluctuations of mind
and the layers of identity conditioning
but empty yourself
of all of creation
empty yourself of even
awareness of even
being of even
i am
and become the ineffable
that gives rise to the i am
and all of creation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
ah
[Music]
[Music]
you